meine herren es werden gefängnisstrafen
angedroht so heißt es tatsächlich im
deutschen parlament denn mit bis zu drei
tagen gefängnis müssen impfgegner
rechnen es gibt hitzige debatten über
die impfpflicht die einen wollen sie
unbedingt verhindern andere sehen es als
pflicht des staates sie einzuführen und
dann kommt sie tatsächlich die
impfpflicht und zwar für die
pockenimpfung das beispiel stammt aus
dem jahr 1874 als im reichstag das
bereichs im gesetz diskutiert und später
auch verabschiedet wird mit strafen von
bis zu 50 mark oder drei tagen gefängnis
für übeltäter die sich trotz amtlicher
aufforderung einer impfung entziehen
heute wird wahrscheinlich niemand mehr
ins gefängnis gehen müssen weil er oder
sie sich nicht impfen lässt aber die
hitzigen debatten über eine impfpflicht
die gibt es auch bei uns heute nur dass
es nicht mehr um das pockenvirus geht
sondern logischerweise um das corona
virus gefühlt hat er in den vergangenen
monaten ein ziemlicher stimmungswandel
stattgefunden habe ich jedenfalls so war
genau aber gibt es diesen
stimmungswandel tatsächlich wollen heute
mehr deutsche die impfpflicht als noch
im sommer wer will sie überhaupt gibt es
unterschiede zwischen den altersgruppen
oder einzelnen regionen genau das
schauen wir uns heute an
[Musik]
in diesem video hier geht es nicht um
vor oder nachteile einer impfpflicht ihr
zeigen euch die einstellungen dazu alle
die sich schon darauf gefreut haben bild
zu argumentieren und in die tasten zu
hauen ich muss euch enttäuschen ihr
könnt das natürlich trotzdem in den
kommentaren machen aber hier geht es um
etwas anderes die meisten argumente sind
ja auch schon ausgetauscht wenn ich das
noch mal interessiert dann klickt gerne
oben auf das i da bekommt die ein
entsprechendes video dazu ihr könnt aber
wie gesagt trotzdem eure meinung da last
in den kommentaren was denkt ihr über
die impfpflicht einfach unten hin
schreiben lassen es dann bis zu
diskutieren übrigens wie die impfpflicht
am ende aussehen könnte das ist noch
vollkommen unklar ob zum beispiel auch
kinder geimpft werden müssen und ab
welchem alter eine empfehlung der stiko
für eine bestimmte altersgruppe muss ja
nicht zwingend in eine impfpflicht
münchen und auch ganz wichtig ist eine
impfpflicht ist kein impfzwang während
im kaiserreich tatsächlich kinder
teilweise noch aus häusern geholt wurden
damit sie von einem arzt geimpft werden
können soll es heute keine gewalt
seitens des staates geben das schließen
alle politisch verantwortlichen deutlich
aus gefängnisstrafen soll es auch nicht
geben menschen die sich der impfung
verweigern würden drohte maximal eine
geldstrafe
so und jetzt schauen wir uns mal die
zahlen an die sind wirklich spannend hat
sich also das stimmungsbild verändert in
den vergangenen monaten so sei es noch
im juli aus 33 der deutschen waren für
eine allgemeine corona impfpflicht 64
prozent waren dagegen drei prozent
wollten sich nicht entscheiden heute im
dezember sieht es so aus 68 prozent der
deutschen sind für eine allgemeine
corona impfpflicht 31 prozent sind
dagegen 1 prozent wissen das nicht
werden die mehrheit der deutschen im
sommer also noch die impfpflicht
abgelehnt hatte würde eine mehrheit sie
jetzt begrüßen ein ziemlicher
meinungsäußerung nein das war nicht
wirklich überrascht und für mich denn
wir hatten im sommer eine ganz andere
lage bei köhler wir hatten viel
niedrigere instanzen und die maßnahmen
waren auch viel lockerer entsprechen
dann aber zum herbst hin hat sich diese
lage eben sehr stark verschärft und wenn
die lage sich so verändert dann
verändert sich natürlich auch die
einstellungen der menschen zu den
maßnahmen die getroffen werden können um
die krise in den griff zu bekommen
der zeitgeist ist hier also entscheidend
und da können sich die einstellungen
auch mal ändern nach dem atomunglück in
fukushima waren auch plötzlich deutlich
weniger deutsche für atomkraft das
misstrauen gegenüber impfungen war
übrigens schon immer da sei dass
impfungen gibt als sich die deutschen
gegen die pocken impfen lassen sollten
hatten einige angst dass sie sich im
kühl verwandeln würden das ist kein
scherz hintergrund bei der pockenimpfung
wurde das für den menschen harmlose
kuhpocken virus gespritzt das macht uns
menschen immun gegen die richtigen gegen
die gefährlichen pocken es gab auch
befürchtungen von katholiken das ihnen
protestantismus eingeimpft wird
inzwischen sind die pocken weltweit
ausgerottet vor allem wegen eines
weltweiten jahrzehntelangen
impfprogramms und so kühlen oder hat die
protestanten wurden wegen der impfung
keine menschen daher gibt es ab 1976 in
deutschland auch keine impfpflicht mehr
gegen die pocken wenn euch die
geschichte des impfens interessiert vor
allem in bezug auf die pocken dann
schaut gerne mal hier in diesem video
vorbei vom kanal des service to go
geschichte im moment gibt es in
deutschland nur eine impfpflicht nämlich
die gegen masern sie gilt für kinder und
erwachsene die nach 1970 geboren sind
den schulen kindergärten arztpraxen
krankenhäusern usw arbeiten oder
unterwegs sind wie die kinder und alle
kinder müssen beim eintritt in den
kindergarten beziehungsweise die schule
die impfung nachweisen die erwachsenen
mit beginn ihrer arbeitstätigkeit
es sei denn sie waren als kind erkrankt
und verfügung noch immer über
ausreichend immunität jetzt aber zurück
zu einer möglichen corona impfpflicht
wer es denn er für sie wer ist gegen sie
haben alter geschlecht politische
einstellungen oder die region hinter
jemand lebt einen einfluss schauen wir
zuerst mal auf das alter 42 prozent der
unter 30 jährigen deutschen sind demnach
im moment für eine impfpflicht bei den
30 bis 39 jährigen sind es 51 prozent
das feld klar auf mit zunehmendem alter
wird der wunsch nach einer impfpflicht
größer ist auch verständlich ältere
menschen sind ja auch stärker durch das
virus gefährdet und haben demnach sicher
eher ein interesse daran dass alle
geimpft sind und corona dadurch
eingedämmt wird auch der blick auf die
parteianhänger ist spannend wenn auch
die verteilung nicht so überraschend ist
rund 80 prozent der anhänger von cdu csu
spd und den grünen sind für eine
impfpflicht bei den anhängern der neuen
regierungspartei fdp und bei der linken
opposition sind es gut die hälfte bei
den fdp anhängern sind nur 31 prozent
für eine impfpflicht gut zwei drittel
lehnen sie ab wir haben auch eine studie
der bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung gefunden haben wir euch wie
alle links und daten unten in der
infobox verlegt da sieht man sehr gut
dass insbesondere die ungeimpften und
diejenigen die gegen eine impfung sind
allen abgefragten institutionen deutlich
weniger das vertrauen aussprechen als
die geimpften diese bevölkerungsgruppe
hat viel weniger vertrauen in das robert
koch institut
das bundesgesundheitsministerium die
gesundheitsämter oder auch in die medien
nur die wissenschaft kommt noch
einigermaßen gut weg aber auch hier
vertrauen die ungeimpften deutlich
weniger den wissenschaftlern als die
geimpften eine große sorge ist ja jetzt
genau die das eine impfpflicht dieses
vertrauen in die staatlichen
institutionen weiter untergräbt nicht
zuletzt auch deshalb weil die
bundesregierung immer wieder betont
hatte das ist keine impfpflicht geben
werde muss man dazu sagen das war die
alte bundesregierung jetzt könnte diese
impfpflicht kommen das wäre kein
direkter wortbruch aber zumindest ein
indirekter die sorge jetzt ist dass sich
die impfgegner weiter radikalisieren und
die spaltung der gesellschaft sich in
dieser frage noch weiter verhärtet
insgesamt wird diese akzeptanz der
impfpflicht in der bevölkerung einfach
davon abhängig wie gut die jetzigen
maßnahmen
sind um diese welle die wir jetzt haben
zu brechen ja vermutet dass
wahrscheinlich dass es regionale
unterschiede gibt dann im osten sind die
impfquoten häufig niedriger als im
westen also könnte da auch die
unterstützung für die impfpflicht
geringer ausfallen ja es gibt einen
unterschied aber der ist eher klein wie
ihr hier seht das könnte damit
zusammenhängen dass die menschen im
osten deutschlands zwar kritischer
gegenüber der impfung an sich sind aber
nicht prinzipiell häufiger eine
impfpflicht ablehnen denn das ist ganz
interessant eine impfpflicht gab es in
der ddr früher auch schon bei anderen
dingen im gegensatz zur alten
bundesrepublik wo man eher auf
überzeugung gesetzt hatte also beim
thema impfpflicht gibt es einen starken
wandel bei der einstellung der menschen
inzwischen ist eine mehrzahl der
deutschen für die impfpflicht ältere
menschen sind mehr dafür als junge und
afg anhänger viel weniger häufig als die
von union und spd zum beispiel der
unterschied zwischen ost und west ist
relativ klein so etwa bei diesem video
hier so oft impfpflicht gesagt dass ich
euch noch einen kleinen fun fact
mitgeben will kein wort im duden hat
nämlich mehr konsonanten hintereinander
als das wort impfpflicht es sind sechs
gibt auch noch ein paar andere wörter
die sechs haben die herbstblumen zum
beispiel aber mehr konsonanten
hintereinander hat kein deutsches wort
also zumindest sprachlich ist das mit
der impfpflicht eine ganz schöne
zumutung kann man nicht so gut
aussprechen das soll es aber für heute
gewesen sei wir leben hier findet ihr
noch das angesprochene video zur
geschichte des impfens und noch eines
zur frage warum umfragen bei der afg so
häufig daneben liegt schaut da gerne mal
rein danke fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]